على سطح الكوكب اصبحنا ثمانيه مليارات
والعالم ينقسم بين الاحتفال والوله خوفا
وتفاعلكم ياخذكم في جوله في بلاكات في
الرياض اكبر فعاليه للامن السبراني في
المنطقه
ولا بروف يكذب اعلام الغرب ويؤكد صحتي زي
الفل اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
فيها رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني
الى مستشفى الكاظميه في يومين للوقوف على
احوال المستشفى
لا عنوان رئيسي بين العراقيين خاصه جمله
معينه غير متوقعه اختصر فيها رئيس الحكومه
الوضع بالمختصر المفيد زي ما بيقولوا
الله يوفقك عليها
لكن شملت كمان الوجبات المقدمه للمرضى
واللي كشفت طبعا ايضا حقيقه مره
مستشفى المستشفى
الاطباء الموجودين هي الناقلون قسم
للطارميه قسم للمحموديه وقسم لابو غريب
كلها قسمت اراء العراقيين يعني في شريحه
رحبت بالتحرك من رئيس الحكومه بس فيتامين
شافوا انه هذه الزياره هي استعراض وشو
اعلامي بس وقالوا انه يعني الاوضاع في
القطاع الصحي معروفه وفي معظم المستشفيات
مش بس في مستشفى واحد
والموضوعيه ليصير في تحرك وتحسين وتغيير
هذا غير اخرين شاف وايضا انه يعني اذا في
كوادر مقصره في هذا المكان ونقلناها لمكان
اخر وين الفائده
[موسيقى]
طيب من سنين واحنا لما حدا بيحكي او بده
يحكي عن سكان العالم وعن عددهم او يعبر
مثلا عن او مثلا عن التدوير ما بين سكان
العالم على شيء كان دايما بيحكي سبعه
مليارات لو سمحت من اليوم هذا تعبير لازم
نغيره فسبعه مليار صاروا ثمانيه مليار
والامم المتحده اعلنت انه تقديراتها تحققت
واليوم يعني 15 نوفمبر 2022 تجاوزز سكان
العالم حاجز الثماني مليارات نسمه بحسب
بيان الامم المتحده نمو سكان العالم من
سبعه مليار الى ثمانيه مليار استغرق حوالي
12 سنه اسباب زياده بحسب الامم المتحده هي
تحسن في الخدمات الصحيه والاجتماعيه
والتغذيه والتنميه الاقتصاديه وغيرها يعني
المفروض انه هذا كلام جميل يعني خبر صار
على كل حال انطونيش الامين العام للامم
المتحده كانت تعليقه على الخبر
باحتفال نوع او قال انه هذه عتبه يتجاوزها
العالم وهي فرصه للاحتفال بالتنوع والتطور
ومراعاه المسؤوليه المشتركه للبشريه اتجاه
الكوكب
طبعا خبر وصوصه كان العالم من الثماني
مليارات نسمه من العناوين الاولى حول
العالم على فكره طبعا وحتى صارت ترند في
معظم الدول وعلى مختلف المنصات وفي الوقت
اللي في ناس في عام لاحتفالات وبتهل
بوصولنا الى ثمانيه مليارات نسمه في ناس
ثانيه منهاره وشايفه انه يا جماعه الكوكب
ما كان حملنا احنا واحنا سبعه مليار فما
بالكم الان واحنا ثمانيه مليار وبتسائل
طبعا او بتسالوا هؤلاء الناس عن موارد
الكوكب هل هي قادره اصلا علينا كلنا وفي
ناس كثير ثاني في النصف مش عارفين شو لازم
يكون موقفها لازم يحتفلوا وينبسطوا واللي
يزعلوا يلطمه على كل حال خلينا نحاول نوصل
لحل مع ضيفنا اللي بنرحب فيه الان هو معنا
عبر الهاتف الدكتور حسين محادين استاذ علم
الاجتماع وعميت كليه العلوم الاجتماعيه في
جامعه مؤته سابقا
فيك دكتور حسين معنا همم في تفاعل لكم
اهلا مساء الخير
ايضا مساء النور طيب دكتور احنا شو
المفروض نعمل مفروض ناخذ هذا الخبر وننبسط
فيه نصرنا ثمانيه مليارات نسمه ولا عن جد
الناس اللي بيلطموا وقاعدين بيقولوا انه
هاي مصيبه علينا هم اللي صح
خلينا نحكي الان مباركه
لهذا الموضوع
الثاني على هذا الكوكب والبعض الاخر الذي
يفكر بعقلي متقدم واستشافيه يقول ان همم
يولد معه تحديات جديده في الحياه ابدا من
المناخ
وتاثيراته المختلفه
نورا بالمعارك والصلامات والحروب هنا
وهناك وليس انتهاء في الزلازل والبراكين
التي من شانها ان تخلص من اعداد
الناس على وجه هذه الكره لكن نقول ايضا من
ناحيه علميه ان هناك علاقه طرديه اي زياده
مع زياده كلما زاد هذا السكان كلما زاد
الضغط على المناخ وادره في الحياه اليوميه
سواء على ارضه في الفضاء
لانه راح يزيد طلبنا على الوقود واللي هو
بدوره بيؤدي للاحتباس الحراري بتغيير
المناخي وما الى ذلك يمكن السؤال الاكبر
او هؤلاء الناس اللي حاسين انه لازم يلطمه
همم هم همم قلقانين بشان الموارد مش بس
موارد الطاقه الاكل همم حتى المكان هل
يسعنا اذا كانت الزياده هاي راح تستمر هل
هناك مشكله في موارد الارض هل هي محدوده
وما راح تكفينا اذا ضلينا نزيد بهذا
الوتيره ولا هذا موضوع خلينا نترك ااا
جماعه نظريه المؤامره اللي همم اللي هن
بيمنوا بهذا الموضوع لانه في ناس بيقولوا
لا ما له دخل موضوع الموارد همم يعني يكفي
ويزيد
وتوزيعه على الارض وتعامل مع الموارد
الطبيعيه والغذائيه بالمجمل لكن ايضا هناك
اختلال في البناء ال-
هذه الارض فالدول التي همم هي الاغنى هي
التي تساهم في همم اذا زياده الضغوط على
حياه الناس من جهه وهناك ايضا تحدي الغذاء
نفسه اذا ان العالم ما اسمه 60 ايات
القانون الماضي كانت يتحدث عن زياده
السكان زياده طرديه متسارعه والموارد
المتاحه محدوده نحن نقول ان الاستثمار
الامثل الموارد التقليل من عوامل اضعاف
واجهات الارض
وتطور العلمي وخصوصا في حقول الزراعه
والغذاء ولا ننساه
مقتنيات البحر بكل عناوين كلها عوامل
مشانها ان توفر فرصه معقوله الى الحياه
لكن ايضا هناك تيار مغاير يرى ان العالم
يجب ان يقف بحدود خمس مليارات والخمسه
الذهبيات كما يصفها هذه الايام
ان هناك ثلاثه مليار الا شويه الى قبل
اليوم يشكلون عبئا على مصادر الموارد
وامكانيه العيش همم اعتقد ان هذا الموضوع
بيثير همم حتى سؤال همم فيما يتعلق
بالاخلاق يعني نوعا ما او سؤال فلسفي انه
طيب هؤلاء من انا ممكن او حضرتك او اي شخص
احنا بنحبه وبنعرفه ممكن يعني يعتبر عبء
نصف سكان الارض يجب التخلص منها يعني
ههه هذول الناس الذين يريدون نظريه
الانتخابات
متقدم وان الضعفاء ليس لهم حق الحياه هذه
النظريه قديمه ولا يمكن ان يمكن ان هناك
من همم ما زال معتقدا باهميه هذه النظريه
رغم القيمه الاخلاقيه التي ذكرناها وقيمه
الانسان الذي كرمه الله عز وجل لامار
الحياه واعمار الارض بالمجمل هناك سيارات
شكريه متباعد لكن الواقع الاوضح هو اننا
اليوم امام رقم ثمانيه مليار انسان على
هذا الكوكب والبعض الاخر ايضا يرى ان هذه
الارض لم تعد تتسع من هذه الاعداد العادي
سوف يفكر في الدائري الى الفضاء وغيره من
العلوم ولا نختبار مثلا قوي اثناء ازمه
الكره
على الفضاء
وعدمه وليد خبرات الانسانيه
اللي بده يفرح يفرح واللي بده يزعل يزعل
اذا هيك شكرا
حزين استاذ علم الاجتماع وعميد كليه
العلوم الاجتماعيه في جامعه مؤته سابقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا فيكم من جديد انطلقت اليوم في الرياض
اكبر فعاليات امن سبراني في المنطقه
الفعاليه بتستمر من 15 نوفمبر لغايه 17
نوفمبر وبتجمع افضل العقول في مجال الامن
السيبراني ضمن فعاليات موسم
بالشراكه مع هيئه الترفيه وبتنظيم ايضا
الاتحاد السعودي للامن السبراني والبرمجه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بلاكات راح يضم اكثر من 200 متحدث عالمي
من 40 دوله حول العالم 50 شركه امن سبراني
رائده وشركات ناشئه ايضا وتحديات ودورات
ومسابقات وجوائز كلها بتصب قيمتها لا
مليون ريال كلها هذا او كل هذا راح يكون
ضمن الفعاليات بلاكات ولا نعرف المزيد
مشاهدينا تنضم الينا الان مراسله العربيه
شهد المتروك اهلا بك يا شهد معنا شهد
حطينا اكثر عن بلاك هاد شو هي الفعاليات
اللي بينظمها كيف كانت نسبه المشاركه لانه
من المتوقع انه يكون في مئات الالاف يعني
الزوار في خلال بلاكات على مدايا يومين
دعم راويه اولا مساء الخير يعني اليوم نحن
متواجدين في معرض بلاك هات وهو اول يوم
لهذا المعرض والذي سيستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام
نتواجد فيه تحديدا في واجهه الرياض يعني
اللي لاحظناه من بدايه دخولنا لهذا المعرض
وهو الازدحام الكبير خصوصا في هذه الثلاثه
لان الازدحام جدا كبير حتى في الخارج هناك
الكثير من المهتمين بمجال الامن السيبراني
والتكنولوجيا والمعلومات همم هناك الكثير
من الشركات المتخصصه بالامن الاسبراني
المشاركه في هذا المعرض روي ساخذك في جوله
قصيره همم يعني ربما لا تعطي حق هذا
المعرض كثيره همم لكن هذا هو المعرض بشكل
هناك تواجد كبير للاشخاص والزوار وحتى
المش اكيد اا في معرض بلاك هات طبعا معرض
بلاك هات هو من ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياضي
هذا العام 2022 همم مستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام
في الكثير من الشركات التي تقوم بعمل ايضا
دورات تدريبيه هناك تفاعل مع حتى زوار
المعرض والمهتمين بمجال الامن همم
السيبراني هناك تفاعل كبير من حيث يعني
مشاركه المعلومات استخدام الاجهزه
الموجوده في هذا المعرض والتي تعرضها ايضا
الشركات همم المشاركه ايضا هناك دورات
تدريبيه تقوم بها هذه الشركات هناك
متحدثين بارزين طبعا في همم هذا المعرض
والذي طبعا سيستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام كل يوم
راح يكون همم في متحدثين مختلفين في هذا
المجال اللي هو الامن السيبراني
والتكنولوجيا والمعلومات طبعا يعني
السعوديه تحاول ان همم يعني تثبت مكانتها
في همم همم يعني همم يعني اهتمام
بالتكنولوجيا والامن السيبراني خصوصا في
المنطقه ومن خلال طبعا موسم الرياض تبرز
هذه الفعاليات وهذا ما نلاحظه في معرض
بلاك هات همم يعني الذي انطلق اليوم ولمده
ثلاثه ايام
وهناك سمعنا في بعض الجوائز ايضا
والمسابقات وجوائز للفائزين
صحيح اليوم همم يعني همم جوائز تصل الى
مليون ريال سعودي للمشاركين والذين ينضمون
الى همم يعني فعاليات اللي تقام في هذا
المعرض التالي سيكون هناك اهتمام اكبر
مشاركه اكبر من يعني الشركات وايضا زوار
هذا المعرض شكرا جزيلا لك مراسله العربيه
شهد المتروك كانت معنا من مقر معرض بلاك
هاد في الرياض
[موسيقى]
مختلف وسائل الاعلام ومن حول العالم اليوم
بتابع مجريات قمه مجموعه العشرين المنعقده
في بالي بسبب ما صحه وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه كان لها نصيب كبير من العناوين
اليوم فبعد وصوله الى جزيره بالي تناقلت
وسائل الاعلام انباء عن نقل المستشفى بسبب
عرض صحي في القلب وقيل ايضا انه اجرها
فحوصات طبيه غادر المستشفى من بعدها
مصادر صحيه
واحنا بنحكي هون يعني وسائل الاعلام
مرموقه يعني اللي نقل الخبر هي وكاله
السوشيه ومصادرهم كانوا اربع مسؤولين
طبيين اندونيسيين من بينهم مدير اداره
الخدمات الصحيه في وزاره الصحه الاردنيه
بروفله تحضير لاجتماعات القمه
ونتابع طبعا شرائط الاخبار او هي قالت انه
ونحن جالسين يعني عم نتابع شرعيه الاخبار
وما عم بنصدق عيوننا من كم تزييف الانباء
وما اكتفت حتى بالمنشور فقط لكن نزلت كمان
فيديو للابراف لا تثبت انه صحته عال العال
ووجه رساله للاعلام الغربي كمان
زومبا اليوم
طبعا اللي بيشوف الفيديو بيقول انه يعني
خلاص افهم الناس وخصوص المعارضين روسيا
واعدائها بالصوت والصوره وقال لهم ووصل
لهم الفكره انه هو فل الفل وصحته على
العالم بس الناس تركت صحته وموضوع القلب
والمستشفى وانتبهت لموضوع ثاني تماما ففي
البنت في الفيديو ومثل ما شايفين امامكم
الان لاحظ الناس تلفون على الطاوله وساعه
في يدها برافو قالوا انه هذول اطول واتش
وايفون يعني منتجات امريكيه يعني قايمه
القيامه ما بين روسيا وما بين امريكا
وعقوبه والف قصه ولافراف بيستعمل منتجات
امريكيه معقول هذا الكلام
اجى عليه رد فلافل الصحفي انه الساعه كانت
ساعه ابل وقال انهاوي وبعد هذا خروفها
وفيه بوست على تلغرام نفلت كمان انه
التليفون يكون ايفون وقالت انه التليفون
مش ايفون ابدا لكن الشغل الوحيد اللي ما
حضرت عليها ولا لحظه
اذا المحبين الفاشل هي التيشرت اللي كان
لابسها لابروف واللي هي من ماركت جون
ميشيل باسكال وهاي بالمناسبه او هذا مصمم
امريكي
[موسيقى]
وصلنا الى ختام حلقه تفاعلكم لهذا اليوم
مشاهدينا شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]